thrown to the sea in the waters of
Dunkirk a tribute to the Dead
it is a year since an overloaded and
flimsy dinghy sank in the channel
31 people died only two survived
they were a mixture of nationalities
United by desire to get to Britain and
the numbers attempting to cross the
channel have been rising ever since
that ambition thrives here in camps like
this one near Dunkirk it's muddy and
squalid
rabbis is from Kurdistan he lost his leg
after an airstrike in Iraq but dreams of
a life in England
we have seen that desire up close
this the scene on the shores of northern
France last week as migrants ran into
the water to clamber onto dinghies
undeterred by any memories of the debts
a year ago
but could that tragedy have been avoided
transcripts are called between emergency
services and the migrants on board the
boat previously revealed by Sky News and
now the subject of an inquiry both
France and Britain face accusations of
negligence
the stricken boat first called the
French Emergency Services shortly before
2 A.M when it was half a mile from
English Waters at 3 31 am another call
saying we are in the water
previous schools have also been
documented some where screams can be
heard in the background
the French operator here replies yes but
you are in English water sir
and then at 416 with still no sign of a
rescue a final call it's over
18 year autonomous on the boat his is
one of four bodies that have never been
found his brother wants to know what
happened out in the channel
foreign
has passed but the memories of this
tragedy do remain strong this region of
France is well accustomed to The Perils
of the sea but this was something
completely different dozens of people
dying in freezing cold Dark Water
waiting for rescue that they had
requested but which never came
tonight a memorial March that wound its
way from the center of Dunkirk and down
towards the beach a year ago a boat full
of people left these Sands hoping for a
new life instead they died the victims
of a cruel sea and a failed rescue Adam
Parson Sky News Dunkirk